you've been doing stand-up for years
you're very good stand-up you've been
doing it for a very long time
why call your special Rory Scovel try
stand-up for the first time it's not a
truth that it doesn't have things don't
have to be true anymore we now know this
this is a marketing tactic the public
the consumer they don't want facts they
don't want the truth they want fun mix
it up so I I've never done stand-up and
I will refute anyone who says otherwise
what's a little stuff my goal I want
someone to and you you probably will not
believe this but there are a lot of
people who still don't know who I am no
that's crazy talk this entire crowd is
like what we do that's why we're here
yeah there's a little hog there like he
needs us to apply do you think you're
why they're here yeah I knew they read
they're like ah let's go see the guy
he's never done stand-up he's never done
the couch he's now let's go see what he
does yeah
yeah say something though you did
stand-up I can prove it you did it when
we had a week of shows at the Apollo
Theatre last fall and you did something
very daring you went out into the crowd
into the audience and did your set from
in the crowd at the Apollo Theater so
look at that clip when you watch a
debate let's stay on point here
the worst just--we're right here folks
all right I'll move she's not really a
team player right now is it and you move
I can't see the show he litter that's
what his thought I can't see the screen
if you're right here sir that wasn't
stand up if we're honest a lot of people
are like all I did was talk to some
people you know you love to perform with
a fake accent sometimes I wonder where
did that come from why did you start
doing that I and this is it's very
thematic tonight all these answers I am
very lazy and so if I get to a point
where I don't have any new jokes I'll
just do it with an accent I'll do the
same jokes I'm like there that's kinda
new nobody will know they're all the
same material I'll do this in a
different but sometimes I'll do this
southern guy I'll just do this go out
and talk about stuff like hey I don't
like how I waved y'all right to clap it
was kind of cool at the end but I didn't
necessarily love it you do that people
like oh maybe it is a different show
it's not I'm lazy I don't write anything
new that guy relied on that audience I
went out there and I was like I even
whisper that guy's like do something I'm
floundering right now that woman's like
that's why I'm not turning around to
watch you're giving me nothing
right right but I like I'll do a German
guy do like a German accident sometimes
there's people who I've done an accident
on this show yes I remember this and
there's I've read the comments on you
unlike the the video afterwards or
you're not supposed to do because
there's a lot of vicious people out
there and some people got into an
argument that there was a real accident
I don't even think I'm doing the
accident that well no that's just real
he's really that's how he really talks
from Austria yeah
you